[Music]
sorry doom fans this is not the BFG
you're thinking of this is instead
Steven Spielberg and Disney joining
forces to bring the classic rolling
dowel book to life it didn't do very
well at the box office and honestly I'd
be lying if I said I didn't see why BFG
is not a bad movie there aren't any
moments that were cringe-worthy or I was
going nuts watching it but at the same
time it does exactly what you expect it
to do with no surprises sophie is a girl
in an orphanage who one night wakes up
and swears she heard something sure
enough she sees it - a giant played by
Mark for Lance
well motion capture but we'll get to
that Abed sees that she sees him and
decides to kidnap her afraid she'll tell
people of his existence he takes her to
the land of giants not exactly knowing
what to do with her but over time as
you'd imagine they spawn a little bit of
a friendship she goes with into mystical
places and even helps him capture dreams
but it turns out he's actually a very
tiny giant and the other bigger Giants
pick on him all the time
one day when he finally fights back they
discover that he's keeping Sophie and
demand to see her when he refuses to
hand her over they decide to go on a
kidnapping spree taking a bunch of
children from their homes to the land of
the Giants so it's up to Sophie and the
Big Friendly Giant to not only stop him
but also alert the Queen and her army to
do something about it growing up I
really loved the original book it was
slow moving but you really kind of felt
this connection it somehow felt mature
even though it was still written for
kids their movie very much tries to
capture that as well as the whimsical
side to it but I feel like Spielberg has
been putting too much emphasis on the
whimsical side and not the realistic
side and I know it's giant it's catching
dreams it's fantasy it's not realistic
at all but part of what made the book so
special is that it felt real there were
a lot of times where they just stood
around and t'adore saw how he put things
together and the different foods and
elements that were all around this world
and again - Spielberg's credit he does
show all that but the problem is unlike
something like ET where the camera can
stay still and you can really feel like
you're in this home with an alien in it
here the camera is always flying always
whizzing music is always going to do do
do it never takes a break
because it's always trying to look so
flashy and impress you you never really
feel like the girl and the giant are in
the same scene even though both the
leaves are incredibly good actors it
always looks like the girl is talking to
nobody and a motion-capture person is
put in later
well the CGI on him is not bad it's not
really convincing either I always think
of Game of Thrones and how they did the
Giant in that show that was just a guy
in makeup and they just used computers
to put him in the same scene they didn't
have to CG everything around him but
didn't have to give him this CG skin
they didn't have to make him look so
flat and shiny doing that creates
another wall of effects we have to look
past it's already one illusion it's
making a normal-sized person look big
but now it's trying to convince you that
the CG skin is really there when clearly
it's not half the time when he's holding
her the effects don't look that great
either she never quite looks right she
looks like this awkward CG puppet like
something out of Polar Express that's
not rendered speaking of which with so
much CG in this movie you gotta wonder
why the hell wasn't it just animated I
mean these giants never move like
they're really there they either move
too fast or like there's no weight to
their actions when you watch something
like Godzilla King Kong or the lore the
Rings movies there's this kind of
movement that feels like they're really
large they slow it down and it gives the
creature such an immense size tool here
they just kind of move like people maybe
a hint slower I know that may seem like
nitpicking but it feels like what
Spielberg is trying to do is make the
moment of this little girl on this giant
talking to each other feel really
special but when you don't feel like
they're really there in the same scene
it doesn't work and it doesn't help that
the cinematography and the effect are
constantly trying to show off you can
have a lot of fancy movement you can
have a lot of fancy music but when all
of them are like that and you don't pace
it out it gets tiring it's like every
scene is trying to be the glowing finger
seen from et separately these scenes are
fine but when you put them all together
it just kind of becomes bland and
generic the only scene that actually
kind of intrigued me comes from this one
actress she placed the Queen and you
might recognize her from Downton Abbey
she has to say the most ridiculous
dialogue she has to say that she had
REME the kids were being kidnapped by
giants and she believes it's real and if
you look out the window you'll see a
girl and a giant that's ridiculous but
by god she sells it and you want to know
why because it's not a fancy scene it's
just a person acting and doing a really
great job no special effects no zooming
around no loud music just a really good
actress acting had this movie focused
more on that it could have been
something really great like the book as
is it's just kind of standard I feel
like Spielberg is kind of behind a what
makes special family films magical Pixar
films have a lot of movement too but it
also takes a lot of chances they know
how to space it out on top of that they
have a really good sense of humor that
connects with both children and adults
here we have violin green farting yeah
there's a whole scene in the Royal
dining room of people rocket farting
into the air there's no punchline no
character-driven joke just farting it's
so pedestrian I can't even get insulted
by it it's just dumb overall though like
I said the movie really isn't that bad
just nothing really stands out about it
that we haven't seen in a million other
films it's tired it's boring it could be
magical but it's trying to be too showy
and inspiring if you saw the trailer and
think you might like it you'll get
exactly what it promised but if you're
looking for something deeper rocket fart
away far far from this
you